[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
albert breer senior nfl reporter and
lead content strategist for the monday
morning quarterback joining us on the
program albert where you want to start
you want to like uh you want a good
theory on why uh the longer extra points
mess with kickers sure
so like what i've heard from a few
special teams coaches over the last few
years that i think is sort of
interesting
is that kickers used to use the extra
point to work out kinks so if they felt
something was a little off or they
thought this or that was wrong
the extra point gave them an in-game
opportunity to sort of work on something
that wasn't that that was either wrong
or didn't feel quite right you know
within their stroke
and so you take that away from them and
now all of a sudden it sort of messes
with the whole equilibrium of being a
kicker and they don't have an in-game
opportunity to sort of work out things
that they did before
so i don't know that's just one theory
out there that i thought was kind of
interesting and that like you know
kicking such a mental game and you know
they used to have each guy used to have
this outlet where you kind of work on
things and now that outlet's been taken
away
i wish there was a deep dive a study of
kickers where you just got into their
heads of of what they go through because
they're really ostracized you know
they're not really a football player
until they come into a game and they can
win or lose a game and i can't imagine
mason crosby yesterday
that you're missing these field goals
you don't miss field goals then you got
to go out there and kick another field
goal just the whole mind game that is
played that kickers you know play with
themselves uh i i i don't know it's it's
something that is probably
not quantifiable in trying to understand
what these guys go through every day or
every week and i talked to him after the
game which was it was interesting
because i asked him about this
conversation he had with matt lafleur
um and he had missed he hadn't just
missed three straight kicks dan he'd
missed like kicks on three straight
possessions right so the packers had
three possessions in a row that that
ended with missed field goals
and on top of that the other kicker had
missed a couple which i mean just sort
of i think would add to it you know like
this is just really weird what's going
on in the stadium and the floor comes
over to him and says
like what do you think and he said i got
this and it wasn't a short field goal
either i think it was what 49 yards
and so yeah i mean i think like this
there's like this
i guess it's almost like i think the
best way to
the best thing to compare it to is being
a golfer right like a golfer who can
compartmentalize
just kind of a slump and you know you
you know you have three four bad holes
in a row and somehow where the rest of
us would be out there and we'd be all
over the place on the on the fourth or
fifth hole in that string these the best
kickers have not have an ability to
compartmentalize
um struggles maybe the way that a good
golfer does and it's i think the other
thing that's sort of interesting in
comparing the two is just being a little
bit off can mean everything is wrong you
know and so
i i just think that the psychology of
the kicker is
really really interesting and you think
back to some of the guys like scott
norwood where one kick just like sort of
like who was a really good kicker just
basically ended his career he never got
it right after that and then you think
about a guy who's you know missing kicks
on three straight possessions and he's
playing on a team where you know every
loss could be one
more or one
every loss could be one fewer game at
lambeau in january the pressure of that
and everything else being able to
compartmentalize it that's definitely a
skill yeah with a golfer you got to play
your misses you know as they always talk
about it kicker doesn't get that
opportunity if you miss then you get it
you know another chance to go up and go
oh we'll be able to try that again the
worst loss yesterday was turned in by
the worst loss yesterday
you know what like i like i don't think
that chiefs losing to the bills was a
bad loss per se
but
i
like think that this is sort of reason
for concern now they've you know they've
they've lost three or five
and some of the pieces that they've
brought in aren't coming together the
way that maybe they'd hoped it had
they're
older on you know in some positions um
you know with guys like tyra and matthew
and frank clark are getting a little bit
further on in the years on defense and
then younger and other positions on
defense with guys like nick bolton and
then they've got all these new pictures
all these new guys on the offensive line
like i just i wonder
how it's going to come to get i wonder
how long it's going to take to come
together because i think anybody who's
paying attention what the chiefs did
this off season knew it might take a
little while for all of that to come
together but i you know like like i
don't know if they expected that they
would get their doors blown off by
buffalo in week five and so
um you know i just think the process in
kansas city is taking a little bit
longer
i don't know there's not like a
particularly like embarrassing loss i
thought the raiders losing to the bears
and they had a good september we were
talking about derek carr
mvp and
now you lose to justin fields
and let's not ignore the elephant on the
couch there either i mean you know like
you know john gruden going through you
know what he's
um what he's what he's gone through the
last three days
and the fact that like i think that a
lot of people across the league not just
people in the raiders building people
across the league were paying attention
like how is that team going to respond
to him now you know because i mean
something like this happens and i think
the the
the honest question for everybody in
that locker room is well if you put that
in an email what else is he saying
and i'm not calling john a liar i don't
know you know whether or not you know
what he's saying is genuine that you
know it wasn't a racial comment and he
didn't mean it that way
but i mean they're going to be guys in
that locker room who are probably asking
that question so
yeah i mean i think it's like in the
same way i think like we had to kind of
watch
not just like whether or not
jacksonville won the game yesterday but
like the effort and how much fight there
was
like i think it's fair to look at the
same things with the raiders on sunday
and kind of look at it and think how are
you going to come out of this so
yeah i mean that's a disappointing loss
for the raiders the bears aren't a bad
team though i think we've kind of gotten
into a space where people think the
bears are a bad team and they've been to
the playoffs two times in the last three
years their tent their top 10 in the nfl
and wins since 2018
so i don't think that's a bad team but i
do agree that like i think
coming off of what the team was coming
off of with everything that happened
with gruden on friday and sort of the
fallout the last couple days it was
important for them to play well and they
didn't play very well i'm just wondering
the nfl is going to investigate but
how far do you investigate because when
you start to look at email
there's probably a lot of things in a
lot of emails that if you start to go i
mean how deep do you go and what do you
want to find out because sometimes you
may not want to find out certain things
here and i wonder if they suspend him if
the raiders suspend him how much uh you
know how heavy-handed is the nfl here
yeah and i don't even know like i don't
know um you know like how you would go
about looking through text messages like
can you can you look up text messages
from 10 years ago why don't you do text
messages they're available from what i'm
told but email
that's something different than
and bruce allen who's on the receiving
end of this you know
he didn't push back on you know john you
shouldn't say that like it just starts
to expand a little bit it's not just
john gruden
this well and it's i mean it like and
honestly like dan it goes back to
everything that's happened the last four
or five years in the league you know
with kaepernick in 2016 and then you
know the comments that bob mcnair made
um and you know i think with every one
of these the question is
if he feels comfortable saying it in
setting x what is he saying and setting
y and setting z you know
and so
you know like i think you're on to it
like where you say how much do they
really want to know do they want to do
are they wanting to dig through john
gruden's text messages from 2011 and his
emails from 2011 and then if they find
something there are they going through
other interactions i mean it could it
can wind up being
a never-ending thing i i will say this
though you know i i think there were
because and there's natural distrust
between players in the league right like
that exists it's always exists it's just
the way it is
like i like i think that there were
a fair number number of players who
looked at the way that the nfl handled
everything in 2020 and liked it and
thought like you're trying to do some
good here
but still sort of wondered how much of
this is just about the moment the
country's in and how much this is just
about
you know public relations and making
sure
that
they're not creating you know they're
not creating a problem for themselves
and so you know i do know that there are
at least some players even some coaches
even some executives that like looked at
the league's effort in 2020
and said let's just see what happens
let's see how they handle you know some
of these situations in the future and i
think some of those people are
definitely looking and saying all right
like let's see what they do with a
prominent coach and are they willing to
come down on a prominent coach in a
situation like this
if this was the nba
what do you think happens if
something was unearthed by an owner
about an owner
okay without having covered it my guess
would be that there would be
um
my guess would be that there would be
prominent players like the most
prominent players in the league out
front and talking about it on social
media that'd be my guess right like and
i don't know you you've been around that
stuff probably more than me been around
the nba more than me but my guess is you
probably have guys like lebron james and
kevin durant like openly openly
commenting on it right yeah and like
once that happens
now we're talking about something else
because now it's
you know now it's it's sort of pitting
players against the league and the
players have put the league on notice
and and i think you know for
a league that's as rabbit eared as the
nfl is
if you had players coming out and saying
something and turning it into a
discussion point in their circles
like now we're talking about something
else that's like how
you know that that's how it you know
happened with that's how the houston
thing became what it became with bob
mcnair you know is that you had guys
like dwayne brown and deandre hopkins
that you know like
literally were like i don't want to play
for that guy anymore and that's how that
became a bigger thing so
i i think you know in situations like
this
the players and i'm not just talking
about the raiders players dan in
situations like this players have more
power than maybe they even think they do
and that like if it becomes a discussion
point any public discussion point in
their circles
things can wind up happening and i think
that if this was a more public
discussion point with you know say
quarterbacks and quarterbacks were
talking about it publicly on social
media the league would probably be
acting would be would be reacting in a
little bit more of an aggressive fashion
is albert breer the monday morning
quarterback senior nfl reporter the jags
lose to the titans
they've got a game in london coming up
and then they have a bye week
where are we headed what happens during
that bye week if anything to urban meyer
i still think that the intention is to
go forward with him as the head coach
um
you know however i i know this like part
of the reason they hired urban in the
first place
is because i think shad khan to some
degree was was embarrassed with the
results that he'd gotten and was
embarrassed with the direction of the
franchise and had sort of recognized
i've got too many things that have been
a certain way in this organization and i
need to bring in a change agent and have
someone in here who's going to shake the
whole place up
and so you know i i think like kind of
like feeling that his organization was
regarded a certain way
in 2020 is why urban meyer is there in
2021 because he wanted to change things
now like now
there's another reason now for him to
feel like you know like
his franchise is being viewed that way
they invested deeply in urban meyer dan
like when when urban went there the
conditions were i need staff and not
just coaching staff but support staff
you know shaw did all that
um i need a practice facility i need a
first class practice facility they're
building a 150 million dollar practice
facility so they're deeply invested in
urban meyer that's why it's hard for me
to see them pulling the plug
but
that was a pretty strong statement that
he put out there and so i think
you know being on that national stage
even though it's i mean it's a london
game but being like a stand-alone game
in that spot
um i think it's an important spot for
urban meyer and i think that they have
to at least play well in that spot um
you know and
for him to sort of i think cool things
off a little bit there my guess is that
you know i don't i don't think urban i
think urban's got too much pride to walk
away um this early
and you remember like when he walked
away florida and ohio state was after a
whole lot of success
um and i
think that you know shad khan you know
given his druthers wants to see this
through
um but a lot of this and urban's right
when he says this a lot of this rides
and how the the locker room yeah you
know decides to handle it and and
whether or not they remain engaged going
forward and i think you know the trip to
london
historically if you look at it because
it's hard going over there has sort of
shown us where coaches stand over the
years yeah i think you bring up the
great point and that's effort if the
team continues to at least try give
effort on the field that's one thing you
know that they don't quit on him uh i'll
leave you with this
the odds of trayvon diggs winning the
nfl defensive player of the year
you know i think that
i think he's got a chance i just think
that
at that position it's so hard like
darrell rivas never won it um jaylen
ramsey hasn't won it like we're talking
about great like i mean rivas is a hall
of famer ramsey's trending that way
and you know what the hard thing about
it is dan is the statistics is that he's
got six picks now but what happens when
teams start throwing away from him you
know and so i think he's got like i
think like he's got a really good shot
to be first team all pro
but the question becomes
if he has say just one or two picks over
his last 10 games which could mean he's
playing fantastic and no one's throwing
at him like then i i think too many of
the voters are gonna look at that and
say
well wait a second like
do can we can we give the award to
somebody who wasn't you know wasn't
making plays in the ball in november and
december even though
that can be a symbol of how well a
corner is playing but he's playing for
the cowboys that's true yeah you gotta
factor that in they didn't have anything
i know
i mean that's crazy think about that
darrell rivas never won it like like
it's just i think it's hard for guys at
that position to do it you know but
stefan gilmore wanted
that's true yeah that's true
he's got a shot he's got a shotgun
he's got a shot i just i i would just
say like if you look at stefan gilmour
the other thing that gilmore had going
for him
that was a really good secondary that he
was a part of in new england right and
so
it was harder to throw away from stefan
gilmore in new england than maybe it was
to throw away from darrell rivas in new
york or champ bailey you know he was a
great player for a lot of years hard to
throw away from champ bailey for a lot
of years in denver
um or easier to throw away easier easier
to throw away yeah like i think with
trayvon diggs it's going to be a little
easier for teams to kind of
work around throwing at him versus what
it was for say steph gilmore in 2009.
you're a buzzkill man
buzzkill buzzkill breer that's what
they're calling it you want you so
you're rooting for trayvon then no i i
just look for impact players uh that
defense was one of the worst that we've
seen in nfl history uh micah parsons has
been a godsend for them but
you have somebody who's changing games
out of nowhere and a second round pick
good stuff he's spectacular too that's
the one thing that will help him yeah
like spectacular from like a highlight
player so i'm with you on that like i
hope he keeps making plays like this
because it's fun to watch i just i don't
know
like like i think what often happened
i'm just telling you i think what often
happens with corners is you know teams
start throwing away from them
good to talk to you amber
sorry to kill the buyers that's all
right that's all right you see it's the
guys i work with that kill my buzz but
it's it's you today albert thank you for
joining us
all right thanks dan that's albert brier
he is the senior nfl reporter the monday
morning quarterback